attention aux prédateurs du web certains
pédophiles utilisent la toile
électronique comme une toile d'araignée
ils avancent masqués en utilisant des
pseudo alors pour accroître la vigilance
des enfants et des parents une
association a décidé de lancer une
campagne de sensibilisation
yoann mal car le regard d'un enfant un
pseudo amical mais derrière le masque un
danger un pédophile en chasse sur
internet depuis une semaine six mille
panneaux comme celui ci s'affiche dans
toute la france objectif de cette
campagne alerter les parents mais aussi
faire réagir les enfants sur les dangers
du web
il ya des gens avec des pseudo
pas très bien et
bah il
on sait très bien voilà les parents ils
font pas spécialement attention mais
c'est vrai que ça peut être dangereux il
ya souvent des gens qui rend compte
qu'ils seront comparés par msn par
internet par en 2005 30% des mineurs se
connecter loin de la surveillance d'un
adulte et 34% d'entre eux disaient avoir
déjà rencontré des contenus choquants
policiers des gendarmes spécialisés
traque les prédateurs sur la toile mais
contrôler les chat privé est une mission
quasi impossible à moins de suivre
justement les passions c'est une
conversation est en privé de personne à
personne non sauf s'il est bien entendu
la personne dépose plainte
onco quelqu'un nous avons les moyens de
remonter jusqu'à l'auteur de
l'infraction faut vraiment faire
attention avec qui l'on parle de pas
envoyé de photo non plus à quelqu'un que
l'on ne connaît pas ni mettre sa photo
sur un blog
d'abord quand on lit mineur il faut
l'autorisation écrite des parents
donc tout ça ce sont des petites choses
qui peuvent paraître très simples qui
sont importantes pour éviter le pire
aujourd'hui seuls 20% des parents
utilisent des logiciels de contrôle
parental pour les associations une
utilisation plus systématique de ces
filtres permettrait pourtant aux enfants
d'éviter de mauvaises rencontres
aujourd'hui le 15 août séjour